[Music]
nestled between high mountains lies the
small town of over tick with its 3,000
inhabitants it seems like any other
small town in Anatolia but look closer
and you'll see the local cafe is called
Cuba and that a picture of Che Guevara
rather than the president hangs in the
Town Hall and that there are no
biographies of a Diwan in the library
but instead of Khrushchev logic is the
only town in Turkey with a communist led
local government this is the mayor
Fatih Mehmet ma troll or a lab
technician elected four years ago with
over 36% to hit a coalition Edwin's AKP
recently got less than 4% of votes much
hulu hates wearing a tie and likes to be
hands-on here people like to help each
other drop shoes off at the Town Hall
someone else will bring books and other
clothes whoever needs something can take
it from here just now a school boy
dropped off some books the underlying
solidarity look these men aren't
employed here volunteers much in
allergic differs from the rest of Turkey
you can buy alcohol without difficulty
and there's hardly a headscarf in sight
although it seems the government doesn't
want too many eyes on this communist-led
spot as civilian policemen stopped us
from filming to continue we have to
agree to restrictions all residents are
invited to town hall meetings in a
verdict even the youngest two council
members are absent Mosholu explains why
one had to work and the other couldn't
attend because he was arrested this
morning
[Music]
the Kurdish council member has been
accused of supporting terrorism part of
everyday life since erawan declared a
state of emergency two years ago
students study for exams in the town
hall library the mayor provides young
people from poorer backgrounds with the
modest University scholarship the
students wouldn't want to live in a city
run by Islamic nationalists our one
supporters things are freer here than in
most places in the country especially
for women it is women who run the
farmers co-op the mayor is proud to show
us where orders for over chicks organic
produce are handled organic salt beans
and honey are dispatched to the whole
country it's a way for opponents of our
Diwan to support the left-wing town we
do three things with the proceeds first
we finance school scholarships second we
support farmers by providing fuel for
their tractors and third we distribute
seed free of charge currently around 250
farmers in the region have joined our
co-op that number is rising these city
employees are collecting soil samples in
a field the coop is to start growing
crops here too president edwin promised
more prosperity for turkeys poorest but
he hasn't kept that promise says this
farmer the price for one kilo of beans
is the equivalent of one year of 50 but
the wholesalers only ever paid us half
of that the local government here
guarantees me that I'll get the full
one-year of 50 within just 14 days video
much Hulu drives a humble compact car
the communist is not only popular among
local residents many seem as a beacon of
hope in Turkey's political discordant
opposition many opposition members have
been neutralized by erawan or put into
prison
matru Lu is aware of the risks we
believe we're doing the right thing if
we're to be punished or I'm to be
stripped of my office then that's the
price we have to pay
and so logic is a glimmer of hope in
these dark times of Turkish politics at
least for as long as everyone will
tolerate it
[Music]